[Music]
and the nice thing about like learning
bslib is it
serves as a general foundation that not
only shiny and r markdown
directly can use but also extension
packages like flex dashboard
and package down and book down like some
of these other
packages that fit into the ecosystem and
essentially like extend our markdown or
extend shining
[Music]
because of how we've sort of approached
this problem
[Music]
so at least a handful of these packages
have pretty nice seamless integration
with
um
the ability to like if you have a theme
that you're already using for your shiny
application
you can pretty easily sort of copy paste
that over to a flex dashboard app or
your package down website or something
like that
if you're using bslib make sure you have
a more recent version of shiny in our
markdown when when you're using it
and the real straightforward basic usage
is to
take advantage of this theme argument
if we're talking about shiny
there's a few different
ways to create sort of the page
container
so if you want that classic navbar page
look you would start with navbar page
and give the theme argument to this bs
theme object
and with this bs theme
function
you can specify the bootstrap version
that you want to use
so i think still
we're defaulting to bootstrap 4 but soon
we will default to bootstrap 5 but
if you want your project to be fully
reproducible we do recommend like fully
specifying the version so that if we
change the default in the future you
won't be surprised that you're getting a
new bootstrap version
um
so this is kind of like the easiest way
to opt in to a new
bootstrap version
is to you know call this be a theme
function give it a version
and pass it to the theme argument of a
page layout
and the equivalent way of doing
something like this in our markdown is
to work with the theme arguments of a
output format
so not all output formats will have a
theme argument
this historically has just been used for
output formats that are html based and
theme has historically meant like
choose a do different bootswatch theme
essentially
so you might have used this and said
something like theme
darkly or themed cyborg or
[Music]
some bootswatch theme
but we've now extended this interface
essentially with bslib so that you can
provide any collection of arguments to
this psd function with all of your
custom theming parameters
and
[Music]
then
essentially this html document will use
all of those custom settings to
influence the css that goes on the page
in the same way that would happen for
the navbar page
so that's you know one of the great
things about learning bslib once is you
can use it in both of those projects
you just have to kind of work around the
fact that
you know this is yaml and not r code so
some of the things that you might be
more easily done over here in the r side
might be a little bit trickier to
convert that to pure yaml if you have
more recent versions of bslib and flex
dashboard
bslib itself comes with some different
templates in our studio
so i could show you
how that looks if i go to file new file
in our studio
[Music]
and then go to our markdown
this
little window will pop up and then if
you choose the from from template option
bslib will provide a few different
[Music]
sort of examples of how to get started
with our markdown
um
and i believe i don't know if i have the
newest version of flex dashboard
but we also have some flex dashboard
templates
that
show you how to use bslib with it
um
so if i just
open that one
this will
give me
like a more
worked out complete theme
and so it's not going to be super clear
or super obvious like one unfortunate
way
about how this currently works which
we're looking to improve in the future
is that
i don't like
how am i going to remember what
arguments go to this theme parameter
um
you know i've i'm using bg here which
represents the background color fg which
represents the foreground color
a primary color secondary and a couple
different font settings
and
i guess the way that
um i keep track of this and i'm hoping
other people will remember this as well
is
you can pass in any
argument to this psd function
to
this theme yaml setting over here
so as you can see the the first few
listed are the bg
as i said a color string for for the
background fg
color string for the foreground
there's a handful of different like
accent color settings
um
so primary is going to be you know the
most obvious one that changes the most
colors
but then it's also possible to
control some other colors with these
other accent color settings
uh there's three
different main settings for fonts so the
base font is going to be kind of like
the global font setting for everything
on the page
code will target you know
um
like code blocks essentially
headings for things like titles
and then you can al also do
some things like scale the fonts to
larger sizes
and eventually we'll get
through
uh
talk about like
the fact that there's actually hundreds
of different theming uh controls that
you have access to
via via bs theme
but they're not all named arguments and
we've kind of intentionally designed
things that way
where we want to
allow you to set any of these sort of
main color and font settings and have it
work across the board on all bootstrap
versions
but then when you get more targeted and
you know set a more specific style on a
very particular thing
um on a website
um
we want to make it a little bit
harder to discover those things and
make you aware of the fact that
this could potentially break with a new
newer version of bootstrap and we're not
like committing to supporting this
across the board
um
so let me actually just show you a real
example of what's going on here um
so
let me just knit this
all right so this is the
template um or the result of that
template
um
so
that main bg setting is going in and
determining like this background color
here
the foreground color
i believe will be used for these text
colors here
um
and the thing about
you know implementing a dark theme like
this that you might want to keep in mind
is you know there's
actually
at least tens if not hundreds of actual
color styles
that are going into the end results on
the page
so for example like the gray on this
background for this code block
is actually like a mixture between the
background and the foreground color
that you're choosing
[Music]
so when you give us those two main
settings you want it to be kind of a
high contrast
difference between
probably two like grayscale colors
so
that's why you know i kind of recommend
you know
first of all it's primarily most useful
for just implementing a dark theme like
this where you just set the background
to something that's close to black and
foreground that's something close to
white then you can easily have a dark
theme here
um but i think people quickly want to
like set like colors with different cues
like a green for a background or
something like that and just be careful
like
if you want to do something like that
you want to set a dark green
like choose
a lighter green for the foreground color
and don't choose like a light red or
something like that because you'll get
mixtures of those two colors that's as
to determine stuff like these code
blocks
also
i've i've kind of
already jumped um
one of the punch lines here where
this template is also showing you
another package that could be kind of
thought of as like a sister package to
bs lib
called thematic
which
essentially allows you to pretty
easily
translate
on some level
the css styles that are going onto the
page
and have those styles actually determine
new global styling defaults for
your r plots
so
to make that happen i just called
thematic rmd since this is an our
markdown document thematic has a
thematic rmd
where
this extra setting will also make it so
that it uses
the font settings that i've set up here
in this document as well to
use that for
the fonts that are in the plot
and the reason why this isn't really
enabled by default is that
you know chances are you don't actually
have the font installed in your r
graphics device
so thematic will actually
in the case that it's detected that you
don't have that font installed it will
actually go out and grab fonts from
google
google's um
font api
so if you're not familiar there's a
fonts.google.com
that
provides you access to like hundreds if
not thousands of different free fonts
and
uh essentially we've tried to design
both these lib and thematic in the sense
of like if you can find the font on
this fonts.google.com
you don't have to do any other work
beyond just specifying the font and
we'll do all the work of downloading and
caching and making sure that that font
is actually available
when people try to view your website at
the end of the day
so there's a lot of work to make that
all that magic happen in the background
if you've ever worked with fonts before
and
i kind of glossed over the fact that
there is kind of a special way to use
google fonts with bslib
um if you're inside of our markdown
you first um
use this be a theme function and you
know remind yourself oh i yeah i want to
change the base font
and
if you want to use this with the normal
our programming usage you have to
remember
oh
i want to actually use a font google
helper
and then give the family name and that's
just kind of an indication to tell bs
that hey this is actually
you know
a font that i want you to make sure like
the font files are actually
included with the end website
and are actually
you know made available and used for
that base font setting
because if you were to do it this way it
would just change the css
style without actually bringing in any
of the actual font files needed to
render that font
so yeah that's an important distinction
to remember
that this is
the way you would want to specify
something like this on the r side like
with shiny
um
but this is the way
you specify it in our markdown
let me just go back to like a more
simple example
with shiny so this is kind of like the
example we saw on the home page for
bslib
um
and let's just you know create a navbar
page
with the typical navbar page usage
so this is just a simple
shiny app
where i have two tabs here a and b and i
can click back and forth to look at page
a and page b
and that's fine um that works
just fine
but let me actually take
show you how i would actually
take this theme from my our markdown
document
and bring that into my shiny app
so i will take those arguments
try to get multiple cursors here
change these colons to equal
make sure i have commas at the end
base font remember requires a special
for google
function
do that for the base font and the
heading font
and now i should be able to run that and
have the same sort of theme look to
something went wrong here forgot a comma
i wonder how much my life has been
wasted on that problem
um so yeah now we got the new different
fonts in there and
again like the navbar background color
is another sort of like mixture between
this darkest black background color that
is going to be used for the body
and the foreground color that's used for
the text
so and these are just warnings that
i actually don't have like the best
contrast ratio
and this is something that uh this is
kind of like a side thing that
i think
more advanced shiny developers might
want to know about that more recently
we've added a function in shiny called
dev mode
where
we kind of set at least a handful of
different options for you that are
convenient for developing shiny
applications
so i actually have this set of my r
profile
and this is a warning that i will only
get in development mode
that
you know obviously we don't always want
to be throwing these warnings when
you're like running this shiny app in
production
so it's something we just like
if we have warnings or other things that
we think only developers should see
that's something we'll only
emit when you have this
dead mode set and to set it all you need
to do is call that function
all right but let's do a little bit more
here
as i mentioned like this bsd yes theme
um
we really only have like 10 or 15
different arguments
documented here
the bootstrap version a bootswatch theme
if you want one and then like the more
like main
color and font settings
but if you want to get more targeted
with your theming
uh hopefully we have a link here
not a great link we could probably
provide a better link here to this
article
on the bslib websites
you'll find this drop down has
both bootstrap 5 and bootstrap 4 sas
variables
and this is a big interactive table with
hundreds of different
theme settings for customizing lots of
different
things that go into bootstrap
just know like if you're new to
bootstrap there's a lot more here than
you probably even want to know about
because
there are
like certain components that bootstrap
makes available that
we
at least currently don't
make that available
super available to you in shiny um so
there are things like
uh
just give you a couple examples like in
bootstrap itself there are some
components like accordions
and
like
alert boxes and carousels
some different components that we don't
like provide like official r wrappers
for in the shiny package but
you know some extension packages make
this stuff available there's like a bs
plus package that has
wrapped some of these components
and some other projects out there
but you know you can also use those
things more directly by
essentially like
taking this html
to implement a carousel and writing that
in r yourself
so if you actually wanted to do
something like that just to quickly show
you
you could basically copy that html over
and say i want this div with an id of
this and a class of this
and a data bs
right of that
um
so there there is an actual r api that
like shiny provides to you to like write
that same html as our code and include
that in your shiny app and lots of
people do that
like write custom html
um
so
like
it would be possible to just like write
the same html and get a carousel but i'm
not gonna actually go through like
a real example of that but just to kind
of point out like there's a whole lot of
like stuff that bootstrap exposes to you
and that's why there's hundreds of
different sas variables is
because if you search this table here
for something like an accordion
there's settings for like setting the
padding on the accordion like the
background color the border with before
like pretty much every single little
small
detail um
that would make sense to have like a
high level control for
they'll provide it to you through this
sas variable theming interface
so
um
not only that we've actually done some
work to like make some common things a
bit easier for
shiny app developers
so one thing in particular is like this
nav bar background color
is not an actual like bootstrap thing
but we've just added it to make your
life easier
where if you wanted to
take this
basic navbar page and
instead of let me just
refresh our memory here and point out
like this kind of
fifty percent gray essentially being
used for the background of this nav bar
i could set this
nav bar
[Music]
dash bg
to purple
now i have a purple background for
my nav bar
and not only that but
bslib will do some extra work to like
make sure that you get a sensible
contrast by default
so if you wanted like
a light blue instead
um notice how on this more darker purple
um
you get a light foreground color to
contrast that dark color
but now if i do a light color
on the nav bar it's flipped the text
color to
dark instead of light
[Music]